hola una vez más estábamos a punto de
pasar a la parte d antes de eso tenemos
que organizar un poco el pizarrón déjame
ver cómo le hacemos bueno para no
recorrer la pantalla vamos a borrar todo
claro procurando que no quede todo
amarillo verdad a ver ahora si ahí va
con negro ya quedó voy a copiar y pegar
la parte ce a lo mejor te preguntas por
qué copio y pego la pregunta si casi ni
se ve pero lo que pasa es que así a mí
me sirve mucho durante todo el problema
bueno el problema dice lo siguiente la
razón en la cual a ver
la razón en la cual los boletos fueron
vendidos en lo de siempre este intervalo
pueda modelarse por rd te déjame
escribir eso por aquí abajo r de t es
igual a 550 t
era la menos te entre dos boletos por
hora basados en este modelo cuántos
boletos se vendieron hasta las tres de
la tarde
o sea párate igual a tres redondea tu
respuesta al entero más cercano ok para
acordarnos de redondear al final lo voy
a marcar con amarillo va entonces como
esta es la razón en la cual se vendieron
los boletos
esta es la derivada de la función de
cuántos boletos se han vendido al tiempo
t otra forma de escribirlo es que el
total de boletos digamos vamos a ponerle
pues no sé
de no no no eso no tiene nada que ver
con los boletos y tdt suena feo mejor le
ponemos ve ok entonces ve de te va a ser
igual a una integral definida y esta
integral va a depender de cada valor de
t ok aquí voy a usar un corolario del
teorema fundamental del cálculo aunque
en algunos casos también se le conoce
directamente como el teorema fundamental
va entonces vedete es igual a la
integral de 0 a t de qué cosa pues si
queremos encontrar b tenemos que
integrar su derivada que es r esto es
igual a esta expresión verdad que es 550
a la menos te entre dos de te vamos a lo
que pide el problema si queremos saber
cuántos boletos se vendieron al tiempo 3
entonces hay que hacer la integral de 0
a 3 de pues de la expresión que tenemos
acá arriba 550 t a la menos de entre 2
dt a lo mejor aquí quieras presumirle a
los evaluadores que sabes integrar por
partes pero no te lo recomiendo a menos
que seas muy veloz recuerda que tienes
sólo 45 minutos para resolver el examen
y además nos dejan usar una calculadora
gráfica a ver chequemos y nos piden el
procedimiento no ok entonces vamos a
sacar la calculadora a ver déjame traer
por aquí mi emulador de la tele
a esta entonces tenemos que copiar
cuidadosamente la expresión le picó por
aquí seconds para ir al menú calc
aquí está calc luego me tengo que ir a
la función integral definida deja muevo
un poco la calcule para copiar es 550 x
x
e
ala
- x dividido entre 2
creo que es todo verdad ajá cerramos
paréntesis coma y aquí hay que poner la
variable
la variable es x fíjate que antes
teníamos t aquí le puse x los límites de
integración son de 0 a 3 cerramos
paréntesis y le damos enter al parecer
se está tardando un poco bueno seguro se
tarda menos que nosotros en hacer la
cuenta 972 puntos 78 falta una cosita
más es redondear el entero más cercano
es 973 lo apuntamos en la pantalla le
ponemos 973 boletos boletos vendidos
hasta las tres de la tarde listo esto
nos tomó muy poco tiempo y seguro toma
menos ya en el examen real nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo para hacer el problema